the death total increasing is about a
100 major wildfires burn in the west at
least 19 people have died in California
Washington and Oregon dozens are appear
missing in fire ravaged Oregon where two
large fires are threatening to emerge
and nearly half a million residents have
been forced to evacuate the governor
describes the air quality as the worst
in the world and warns of what she calls
a mass fatality incident with more than
a million Acres burned so far this as
powerful dry winds fuel fires in C
California where Governor Gavin Newsome
describes the latest Devastation which
has destroyed thousands of homes and
burned through more than 3 million Acres
as signs of a climate emergency da bakus
is on the ground in Fresno County
California this morning da good
morning good morning to you Jeff the
destruction is staggering officials here
in Fresno County say more than 300
structures have been wiped out by the
Creek Fire the fires have been moving so
quickly and there's so many that they're
over running Crews throughout States
here in the
west more than a million acres in the
west ravaged and scorched so far in a
fire season that is not even half over
and taking a tragic toll the magnitude
of which is still unknown there are
early reports from from our state police
that there are dozens of missing persons
related to the fires Oregon's Governor
Kate Brown is pointing to the towns
called talent and Phoenix where
Searchers are looking for the missing
smoke from Oregon's three major fires is
unimaginably widespread its worst air
quality in the world is choking the
Pacific Coastline Seattle skyline to the
north San Francisco more than 800 miles
to the South and then to Los Angeles the
scenes and sickening air underscore for
many that the climate is in crisis
Washington's Governor Jay Ensley I think
we have to start thinking there're more
climate fires because that's what
creates the conditions that makes them
so explosive this is a climate damn
emergency this is real and it's
happening this is the perfect storm
California's governor Gavin Nome T
destruction north of Sacramento where
more than a quar million Acres burned in
a national forest the reality here is
the mega fires that we're
experiencing come from these Mega
droughts that we've experienced
people who did make it out have
harrowing stories to tell eight of us
had to go down to the end of our road go
into the sand and get down in the water
to avoid the fire Denise Hendrickson
left her home in Lake Orville California
an area now prone to fires I've survived
four different fires up there until this
one and now I don't even know if my my
home is standing at this point but this
man's house is gone again 2 years after
fire claimed his home in a Comm
Community nearby it hurts more this time
I think than last time and getting
things back together again and and
having to rebuild is rather devastating
while there is relief expected with rain
in the Northwest tomorrow night there
really is no end in sight people tweet
the photographs of what San Francisco
looked like yesterday and say oh 2020
could you get any worse as if once we're
in 2021 these kinds of disasters are
going to stop happening climate
scientists point to Human Behavior
namely burning of fossil fuels including
coal and oil for increased temperatures
that decimate forest and make them prone
to
burn Oregon officials are now saying
they are preparing for a mass fatality
incident saying there is a possibility
that they will not have enough resources
to handle the dead Dana da those
pictures look like an apocalyptic movie
straight out of Hollywood thank you da
be safe